uh check out this school the school is
pretty cool a new york public school
principal sent a letter to white parents
advocating for white abolition
and urging students to become traitors
to their race school employees are
forced to attend presentations
denouncing the white race
paternalism and power hoarding and why
uh
so this is here we go this is this is
one of the things that the principal
sent out to the
parents which i think is pretty there's
a couple of them let's do this one first
so as you can see here there's a little
chart there's there's only
from barnard hess
there's only eight kinds of white
identity okay okay
so let's see where you fall i really
want to figure out where you guys fall
on the list okay
uh according to this new york principle
your options are
white white voyeurism
white privilege white benefit
white confessional white critical
white trader or white abolitionist
so we keep getting told that we're like
white nationally we're all
horrible racist right but why is it that
i feel like the more i do this show
the more i feel like i am the least
obsessed with race
out of anybody else in this country do
you not get that feeling when you do
this show like
you keep getting called a racist and
you're like you're the one that keeps
making white people charts
like i don't go home after the show and
go i need to make another black people
chart
you know what i mean i need to chart how
terrible the blacks are somebody get me
a venn diagram i need to prove how bad
black people are
not true because i do that every year
it's called fantasy football okay well
that's different
it's it's so you know to be fair i don't
get why
why i keep getting called racist i'm not
making charts
you're right uh jim edwards says you
should take the test two royce you're
white now
okay i'll take it i'll look at it and uh
kitty says the voyeurism one sounds fun
it's not what you think you're looking
at white people's buttholes i don't
think so anyway
um so there's a little bit more to this
so if you want a little background this
is uh this is a
description of them this is what the
principal sent
the eight white identities there is a
regime of whiteness and there are
action-oriented white identities people
who identify with whiteness
are one of these it's about time we
build
an ethnography
okay of whiteness since white people
have been the ones
writing about and governing others
number one this is like oh you know what
hold on
i i i feel like they're getting white
people and confused again though
i know the people that rule over you
look white i know
it could be very deceiving sometimes
okay so not what do you mean they're not
uh in what way mike they look white
they always they always say they're
right
so do you want to maybe you want to
maybe read these mic because you do the
better letterman do you want to read
these like letterman uh
uh i don't actually do a good letter
okay did you know i don't really do a
letter all right well i'm gonna
i'm not gonna i will read it though
number one
lights are supposed to do it
from the bottom up if you're doing it if
you're doing a letterman top 10 list
well we'd have eight so we'll start at
eight okay
here we go number eight white
abolitionist
abolitionist changing institutions
dismantling whiteness and not allowing
whiteness to reassert
itself
ah dismantling whiteness number seven
i wish i had a [ __ ] keyboard that i
could just fight
white traitor actively refuses
complicity
names what's going on uh names is going
on intention is to subvert white
authority and tell the truth
at whatever cost need them to dismantle
institutions
so they're uh they're dismantling
institutions huh
they're naming what's going on yeah
white critical
take on board critics of whiteness and
invest
in exposing marking the white regime
refuses to be complicit with the regime
whiteness
speaking back to whiteness
number five why confessional
confessional
some exposure of whiteness takes place
but as a way of being accountable to
pocs
after seek validation from pocs
number four sympathetic to a set of
issues
but only privately won't speak or act in
solidarity
publicly because benefiting through
whiteness in public
some pocs are in this category as well
ah so some of the uh some of the
coloreds
also do that stuff huh white privilege
number three white privilege make
critique supremacy but deep
investment in questions of fairness
equality under the normalization of
whiteness
and white rule sworn goal of diversity
number two white voyeurism
wouldn't challenge a white supremacist
desires non-whiteness because it's
interesting pleasurable and seeks to
control the consumption and apparition
of non-whiteness fascination with
culture example consuming black culture
without the burden of blackness
and the number one
the number one thing you could be from
the eight white identities is
lonnie donegan
david letterman kicked off the year
today
david letterman has been let go after 30
years of cbs
number one ironically by les moonmez who
is well
you know number one is white clearly
mark white society that preserves names
and values white superiority
so uh whichever one you fall on please
uh we'll be giving handing out stickers
at the end so people know who you are
can i do the eight you want to be black
identities can we change it to that
can we well no because we need to try to
make a living here
can't we can't we're not allowed we're
not allowed to criticize the black
okay you know mike hispanics ten years
ago that actually would have been a good
bit
we can't we're not allowed to do it i
mean i know we're not but that would
have been a really good bit
you guys make it up in your head it
would have been really funny and we
would have had a great we've been
laughing at it
people been like oh those [ __ ] rcc
guys are so funny but now you know
you're not allowed because it's this
literal hate crime
again though just the fact that i keep
getting told that
i am a whitening is obsessed with racism
and i've never in my life made a chart
about black people or white people or
chinese people
or any of that hold on whether all the
car crayon drawings in the spare room
well that's actually something else
that's a little different those are
mike's
as he calls him his list of people that
he's going to
murder for crossing him
it's all for a joke though it's all joke
it's just a mental exercise
what about that sign that says this is
not a joke please don't take this as
it's a little mental exercise i like to
do never mind that half the names are
crossed off
that son of a [ __ ] slipped me a fake 20
for some fent i sold him
that'll t that'll learn him